se trata de una de las retiradas más
importantes por parte de Rusia desde el
comienzo de la Guerra el Ministerio de
defensa ruso ordenó a sus tropas que se
retirarán de la ciudad ucraniana gerson
Moscú aseguró que ya no era posible
llevar provisiones a la ciudad sureña y
que debían cuidar la vida de sus
soldados ante un importante avance de
Ucrania para retomar la reciente ciudad
anexada por Rusia
entiendo que esta es una decisión muy
difícil pero al mismo tiempo
preservaremos lo más importante la vida
de nuestros militares y en general la
efectividad de combate del grupo de
tropas que es inútil mantener
esta semana las autoridades prorusas
instaladas por Moscú en gerson habían
asegurado que las medidas para reubicar
a más de 100.000 ciudadanos habían sido
completadas muchos de los evacuados
fueron recibidos en la Península de
crimea también anexada por Moscú en 2014
los ocupantes se están yendo y la tarea
más crítica para ellos es fortalecer los
puntos que están haciendo actualmente en
mi propia en consecuencia en los accesos
en dirección a La Represa hidroeléctrica
no vaca cosa
en el marco de la batalla por la ciudad
sureña
Moscú también ha tenido otras pérdidas
horas antes de La retirada rusa se
conoció que el vicegobernador de gerson
instalado por Rusia falleció en un
accidente automovilístico una cara
conocida en redes sociales quien en la
semana recientes y con teléfono en mano
actualizaba de manera constante la
información de las evacuaciones en la
estratégica ciudad
en otro duro golpe para Moscú el
sacerdote y soldado ruso Michael
basiliev habría fallecido en un
bombardeo de kief en gerson mientras las
tropas de bolodimir selenski avanzan con
la esperanza de recuperar terreno
perdido
[Música]